hello everybody
Perry here at Sundance 2019 and I am
super excited to be talking to the
director of the hole on the ground and
his stars right now and we're really
lucky to be here we have to thank can
you tell your ID because we're gonna
cover a whole bunch of movies so huge
thanks to them for making this happen I
want to welcome Lee James and Shauna to
our interview suite right now I am so
happy to have you and I think you
already know how much I love your movie
the hole in the ground thanks for having
us yeah thank you for having us yeah
absolutely great to be here is it a
first-time Sundance experience happening
right now yep first time in Sundance for
all of us actually I think did you get
any Sundance tips or pointers especially
before your big premiere last night Wow
dress warmly which I did not pack for
well the weather is amazing today free
drink lots of water which I did but I
still got altitude sickness somehow so
yeah I'm 90% water girl I need to know
what happens no you seem okay
yeah I have a lot of coffee in my system
and not a lot of water so I'm still a
little concerned has it been for you so
far James I'm glad to hear it so before
I jump into all of my specific questions
I have many questions about the making
of this movie I want to leave it to you
so I don't spoil anything or go too far
can you explain to our viewership what
the hole in the ground is about of
course so the hole in the ground is a
psychological horror movie about a young
single mother who moves out to the
countryside played by Shana here and
brings her little boy James
he plays Chris out to the countryside in
Ireland and near the house they
discovered this enormous sinkhole in the
earth like this really big hole in the
ground and James's behavior starts to
shift after that point and Sarah starts
to wonder about the identity and
behavior of her boy she goes down this
this kind of rabbit hole of doubt that
takes her further and further into
darker and darker territory I guess I
can't say much more about ruining it
probably an appropriate place to stop
first feature for you and if you already
know how much I love ghost train I'm
very curious why make your feature debut
with this particular story because I
could get it funded I guess like you
know at like Norway where I'd worked on
a number of things but it was a story I
was quite passionate about and
particularly the dynamics of the
relationship I just thought there was
something really interesting to mine in
there and it was a great mystery to be
told and I had been working on a couple
of other ideas but this was the woman
kind of in the in that race that just
that just jumped ahead and felt like the
right thing to do there's one of those
other ideas happen to be a feature
adaptation for Ghost Ranch the draft
three months ago yeah yeah that was one
of the greatest things you could have
said right now I also want to know about
the three of you coming together here
was it a traditional audition process
are we talking a whole bunch of
chemistry Reed's too because the
connection between you two feels so real
right out the gate and I was so
impressed by that yeah I guess I suppose
I should answer that question terms I
hope had the guys came together like I'd
written the character of Sarah
originally and maybe not not not as it
should have been she was a little bit
too on-the-nose and I was looking at
actors that maybe weren't kind of
correct and I've been living abroad and
I'd missed the movie that Shana was in
my produce said you gotta watch this a
day for Mad Mary and I watched it and I
was like okay let's stop looking this is
who we need to go get and then I met
Shauna then I rewrote the script with
Shaun in mind because she's such a great
internal charisma and how she kind of
behaves as Sarah and then with James we
looked at you know a number of young
performers but he was always just
hunting everybody down all the time he
was always in the mix and I know we did
do a chemistry test but it was very very
clear you know that that was going to be
kind of James and Shawna and then we
kind of did some mother and son time and
allowed you guys get to know each other
and hung out a little bit and did some
rehearsals so it was a great process for
me was actually really easy because
quite quickly I was like yep that's them
let's go what was your first impression
of the script actually to backtrack a
little are you both horror movie fans I
I wouldn't I wouldn't usually watch
horror movies books from from last night
watching on the ground it wasn't as
scary as I thought it would be so it
fine yet what's the scariest movie
you've ever seen was it scary onset or
is it okay because you know it's all
faker on you
yeah I know it's just all pretend but
either way it's it's nice to just
imagine that you're actually in ask the
actual part where the sesh where the set
is you you were scary on set though for
the record I was the problem we had how
do you feel about spiders tasty
appropriate and how about your honor
are you into our movies was this kind of
you know up your alley in terms of your
taste in movies I am such a scaredy cat
so I am I'm into Horrors but I get so
afraid even watching this movie at
certain points I'm like come on what
should come on like hurry hurry up and
you know I just wanted to be resolved so
tension for me as always and Lee's so
great a creating tension within the
movie and I'm just like oh like when can
this stuff so I wouldn't be a huge
horror movie fan because I hate that
tension but that's what horror is and
but that's why I was drawn to it as well
it was a genre that I wasn't really
familiar with and I was excited to make
that and especially what entailed within
this movie like with stones and how
physical it was and um being scared
what was the set like for this is it a
big crew you're working with and is
everything kind of practical and on
location here yeah it was it was pretty
compact crew wise like it's it's it's
still you know it's a low-budget
independent movie and it was quite a
tight group of people that we had you
know there was everybody was working all
the time no no one was idle em and we
kind of a lot of the film was set in the
house so we shot it on location it that
in in a real house em which provided a
lot of challenges because you can't move
walls and you know you have to be quite
clever and creating that that atmosphere
that I wanted within it and then we were
on location we were outdoors quite a bit
as well and
and yet obviously then we otter had her
sinkhole and a few other place so we
were on the move a little bit but not
kind of not not too much but we tried to
keep everything as Pratt like across the
board at the film from how he shot it
even through to the music and the sort
of instrumentation we used tried to keep
everything as practical as I possibly
could the sinkhole is visual effects
though some of it we sent a guy up
digging one day no yeah it is but no
there's element there's a lot of real
elements within it so even just textures
I tried to shoot as much real stuff as
like Hannah there is certain shots we
didn't like close-ups or say feet
passing a by that are actually real
completely real landscape and I think
the more you can you can do that the
more you can kind of I suppose pull the
world over the eyes with the CG work
that you do I was wondering if you guys
could break down shooting one particular
scene for me and it's you know a
non-spoiler type thing but I was really
struck by the scene with you running
through the woods with just the
flashlight and just the blackness around
it so while you're shooting something
like that is it that pitch-black feel
and is it as chaotic as it feels for a
viewer well how was it for you I guess
like that was that was that was tough
stuff because I was cold
yeah the cold was the least of your
worries but it was it's quite yeah
you're you're in a heightened state
anyway so and with the flashlight and
every every year
emotions are kind of or pair B as Sarah
she's trying to keep a lid on this boil
and part of emotions so it can be quite
difficult and yeah you just have the
flashlight but me personally it is that
that frantic even if it is eternal there
was and then when you see it fells very
Blair which II and at times I like
within the film I get jumps and in it
while there were it was a fun scene to
cut because we we shot obviously we shot
some angles on unshown and her reactions
but we'd also just had our cameraman you
know it would essentially what a torch
just moving through and we were able to
find these little moments like like
where he tripped with the camera we were
like great let's put in the we went back
and did some like ad or work let's get
Shana tripping and her breath changing
we're able to create all this this
tension around but I think James is the
hardest thing of all because you have to
like you to like be topless tiny little
mama down it was cold but get him behind
the tree take your top off dude
yeah how was that did you not like the
cold it was very cold up in the woods
Bush
it was bearable okay that's good it's
true I've paid a picture on my phone of
them like rock dough blankets you got to
do what you got to do in these
situations
I was wondering did you give them any
reference films before jumping into this
I totally get any majors I didn't say go
watch this if you know to mean I'd like
there's certain touch points I always
have that I'll always dig back into that
we kind of discuss I can't remember
actually Sean it was when I said like go
watch this or go watch that yeah yes
yeah there was a there was a couple on a
list but as well as that I think when
you're shooting a movie the character
doesn't know they're in a horror movie
this is just what they're dealing with
in life
what was good tonally and to look at
movies and see where Lee was pitching it
and as well we use music on set and for
Lee to create the atmosphere for me and
help me to get places emotionally and
yeah to heighten tension so this is
largely a mother/son story but there's
also a really intriguing mystery
unfolding as well and I think you strike
a really nice balance between leaving
people in a satisfied place but also not
over explaining anything so what is it
like for you figuring out that balance
and then did you give your cast members
any specific details that maybe we don't
see on screen it's it's painful to
figure it out when you're trying to I
think we were trying to subvert the
tropes as much as we possibly could and
I'm sure there's some people that watch
the movie and want certain pieces of
information I haven't given them so what
I'd say watch it twice because it is all
in there if you really dig in
there's if there's a lot of information
hiding in the shadows enough film and
but it was it was tricky to do and I
think what for me again I didn't like
with with Shana and even with the way we
wanted the film to be was there was no
like rulebook there was no you know sage
saying don't go into the woods or don't
do this that didn't exist in the film so
she was you know unaware of what was
coming around the corner even when it
came to the monstrous stuff you'd very
little idea of how that was gonna be so
I tried to conceal as much of that as
possible because the idea was if you
face a monster say in the real world you
know you don't get a rulebook you don't
get the set of information you just you
face it and you deal with it you either
deal order you run away and with Sarah's
character she'd already been running
away for a long time and then she had to
come Stan
open-faced or demons all right before we
wrap this up we like to play a game on
collider cold would you rather all movie
based questions so it's picking between
two options and then telling me why you
would choose one or the other first for
the two of you would you rather screw up
every single take yourself or if someone
else mess up your best take that stuff
and I think I'd rather screw up my take
than someone ruin my best take that's
what my answer is today maybe would be
different tomorrow able to damage your
take no matter what he does yeah I had a
feeling I wonder does not surprise me
one bit
would you rather have to get in the
headspace for a scary scene yourself or
have your director surprised scare you
would you rather get into a scary scene
yourself like get yourself in that mood
or have ly surprise scare you while
you're shooting a scene I think probably
the first one because it feeling like
say filling your head with okay this is
so scary I need to get out of here like
Anna say you're in a haunted house that
that would be just like the experience
of being on cess in on a scary cess just
you know that it's all pretend
unless that you're actually being
followed by a monster somewhere
reasonable right there would you rather
have to laugh or cry in a scene I can
make it answer that one for you why did
you try to cry oh you're good crier but
yet laughing to get an authentic laugh
on camera and that's like yeah that's a
tricky one to do a tough follow-up would
you rather have to fake sneeze or fake
vomit on screen
I think I think it would actually be
more easy to fake vomit because usually
you wouldn't like you be on chair maybe
I mean just be vomiting over the side
the camera wouldn't actually see
vomiting just you'd have a book at there
you can make the noise there's no
problem but sneezing then is you just
have a tissue over your actual over your
mouth and you have to make the note
noise and then you have to I agree
like it would be easier it's so hard to
make a fake sneeze noise - I just don't
get how people pull that off
would you rather lame have to test
screen your movie or just go with your
gut
I'd rather test screen every I think
audience reactions so important and we
did test this film at various rough
stages even had a really rough stage
rooster with some storyboards you know
frames of CG shots and stuff in that
that we hadn't done so yeah I would I
would always rather rather test yeah I
think so and lastly I love horror movies
I love anything that gives me a quick
fleeting thrill just for fun or
entertainment but it's something
different when a movie really sticks
with you and you could take it home with
you and I think that's what this
achieves but in your own words what do
you hope people walk away from the hole
in the ground with and I hope they enjoy
it I hope they get to go and sit in the
cinnamon seat in a dark room and I think
they take it out what I'd like to take
them to take home I suppose the twisted
part of me wants them to go home and
look at a loved one and just think ooh
what if and that's the things I think
that's if that's tasted you then that
spreads with word of mouth and I think
what horror if you can if you can give
somebody something to really take away
and and that would be the thing I'd like
to go for for sure success okay thank
you guys so much
yeah me and today it was such a treat
thank you out there to everybody who's
watching as always please like and share
this video and keep an eye out for the
hole in the ground we'll see you soon
you